um for our final Talk of the day uh we
have Fiona who is a graduate PhD student
here at Berkeley
um and heading to Stanford so we're
excited to hear about how great I think
Collective action
um
so as Michael said today I'll tell you a
little bit
a little bit work on algorithmic
Collective action and machine learning
and this is joined work with Moritz
who's here uh Eric mazumdar from Caltech
and salsan Mendler Dunner from Max Blanc
in tubing in
so we all know that online platforms are
everywhere around us and we know that
they can have a significant influence
over our everyday lives and what's
interesting is that we're seeing an
increasing number of examples of people
trying to limit or control this
influence so our starting observation
today is that we're seeing numerous
examples of emerging collectives
strategizing against online platforms
so this has been observed in the context
of the ride sharing gig economy
um for example Uber drivers have been
observed to coordinate uh massive app
deactivations that would artificially
create a dip in the supply of drivers
and thus activate surge pricing and then
once surge pricing is activated they
would turn the app back on and enjoy
these um higher prices
something similar has been observed for
DD so DD is the Chinese analog of uber
here it's been documented up to 40 of DD
drivers use third-party apps and Bots to
manipulate the DD algorithm into giving
higher paying rides
a similar kind of phenomenon is observed
in the context of social media so um
here Twitter users have been observed to
coordinate to come up with strategies to
um share and publicly criticize high
profile Twitter content that they
disagree with but without triggering the
algorithmic proliferation of such
content so what they would do is they
would take screenshots of these posts
that they disagree with and then they
would share screenshots instead of
retweeting directly through the app
because retweeting triggers the
algorithm into perceiving the content as
more popular
and as a final example we see something
similar in the context of traffic
navigation so
um here there are many cases many
documented cases of people fabricating
uh reports of fake traffic accidents in
order to deter a traffic navigation
systems from uh routing loud noisy
traffic uh through their local
neighborhoods and so what's interesting
to note here is that these online
platforms are powered by Machine
learning which in turn means that they
are powered by data and this is really
what gives these collectives uh leverage
so collectives use data as a leverage
over these online Platforms in all these
examples
and so the main question that we'll be
uh trying to address today is what
leverage does a collective have over a
machine learning powered platform
and so to study this question we will
look at the following mathematical model
of the problem
so we will assume that there's an
initial population of individuals whose
data is sampled from a base distribution
P0
and uh throughout the talk you should
think of the typically think of data
points as consisting of feature label
pairs
then an alpha fraction of this
population joins the collective and the
remaining one minus Alpha fraction
doesn't so throughout we will be
denoting by Alpha the fraction uh of the
population that joins the collective
now this one minus Alpha fraction that
doesn't join they just report their
original data which again was sampled
from P0
and the collective applies some kind of
algorithmic strategy to uh craft a new
data distribution that we will denote by
P star
and then finally at the end the platform
observes the distribution P that is just
a mixture of these two distributions so
p is a mixture where um
Alpha fraction of the mixture consists
of this distribution B star that was
crafted by the collective and the
remaining one minus Alpha fraction
consists of P0 which corresponds to the
data of the rest of the population
okay and so now on the platform side
um the platform observes this
distribution p and runs some learning
algorithm a that produces a classifier
that we will denote by f
and the collective School in this
setting is to maximize some measure of
success that depends on F so throughout
the talk we will give different examples
of what success could mean but for now
if you want a running example you can
think of one of the examples that I gave
at the beginning for example a
collective will succeed if traffic is
not routed through their neighborhood
and here I just want to emphasize that
success need not be adversarial to the
platform so the collective does not aim
to lower the the platform's training
accuracy or they do not aim to minimize
their profit so their measure of success
need not be correlated or
anti-correlated with uh with the
platform's goals
and so we'll use this uh as of author
notation to denote the success rate
that's achieved by a collective of size
Alpha
okay so now I'll give a brief overview
of the main results
we study three basic learning theoretic
settings
um optimal prediction convex risk
minimization and possibly non-convex
gradient-based learning so for the
purpose of this talk I'll mainly focus
on optimal prediction and I will give a
brief overview of the results on convex
risk minimization
in each of these settings we study
natural measures of success as well as
strategies that the collective can
implement
and we give lower bounds on the success
rate for the collective
and what's interesting is that we
observe that even small collectives can
succeed on machine learning power
platforms so the fact that these people
are coordinating can actually give them
significant leverage over machine
learning power platforms
um and we also run some experiments on
skill classification tasks that involves
freelancing resumes and these
experiments confirm many of the
takeaways that we observe in our Theory
okay so I'll start with optimal
prediction so first I want to Define
what I mean by Optimal prediction so
here we assume that the platform deploys
the optimal classifier on The observed
distribution P where recall the p is
this mixture distribution where uh the
alpha an alpha fraction consists of P
star and one minus Alpha of P0 so this
is just the base optimal classifier with
respect to the zero one loss
and we also allow approximately optimal
classifiers in a particular sense
um specifically we'll say that a
classifier is Epsilon optimal if it is
optimal for a distribution that's close
to p uh in TV distance Epsilon closed
okay and so in this setting we study two
goals
um so the first goal is planting a
signal
the second one is erasing a signal
so this is the formal definition of
planting a signal so we assume that
there is some transformation uh G and
the target label y star and this is how
we measure success so the way you should
think of G as a light transformation to
your features for example adding some
imperceptible Watermark to your data or
making some slight syntactic changes uh
to your resume so that's a
transformation that you would like to
apply to your data at test time and Y
star is the label that you would like to
produce at that time so
this s of offer really captures our
ability to provoke a Target
classification attachment
just to give a cartoon example let's say
that this is my original raw data if I
give the classifier in my raw data the
classifier might think that I'm a koala
but maybe if I just apply a slight
Watermark to my data that says python
then maybe the classifier will think
that I'm actually a software engineer
such that for all X this
no so here I'm looking at the
probability where X is sampled from the
base distribution so at that time I'm
assuming that X will be sampled from the
same distribution as before and G is a
transformation that the collective
agrees on so we're all saying like we
want classification y star when we apply
this transformation
let's fix G
so you can think about this as uh at the
faster we want as big of a fraction of
the test points as possible to get
classification wise so when they apply
this transformation
um and now if we're erasing the signal
this is our goal
um so again we assume that there's a map
uh G and we're basically here saying
that we want the classifier to ignore
any information that's contained in X
but is not contained in G so we want the
classifier to produce the same
prediction if we give it X and if we
give it g of x
and again to give a concrete example
maybe the platform knows that I'm a PhD
student that I'm female either I do
computer science
and now maybe G of X is a transformation
of my data where I remove gender so
maybe I want the platform to give me the
same prediction
um if if my gender is removed from the
data
so I'll begin with uh planting a signal
so this is the objective that we defined
previously and in this setting we
consider two strategies
so the first strategy is one where we're
allowed to manipulate both our features
and labels so here given data X Y we
naturally just report G of X and Y star
so this is the most obvious strategy to
correlate G of X and Y star
and then the other strategy that we
consider is one where we assume that the
label is maybe difficult to manipulate
in some cases so here we're just
changing features so given data X Y we
will report Port G of X and Y only if Y
is equal to Y star otherwise we will
just uh report the original data
and here a key parameter uh in the
setting will be the uniqueness of the
signal so we will say that a signal is
PSI unique if under the base
distribution G of X has measure at most
PSI
okay and so um these are the definitions
that we just saw so this brings me to
the first result that I wanted to state
so we show that using the feature label
strategy the collective acting against
an absolute on optimal classifier has a
success rate that's lower bounded by
this expression and so there's a lot of
stuff happening here so I just want to
decompose the result term by term
so first we see the effect of collective
size so naturally the bigger the
collective is the higher hour uh success
rate will be
then we see the effect of sub-optimality
of Y star so if y star is already
optimal on G of X then this Delta term
will just be equal to zero and our
success will be high and then the more
sub-optimal y star is the lower our
success rate will be as expected
then we see the effect of signal
uniqueness so the more unique the signal
is the higher our success rate will be
and finally we see
um the effect of classifier
sub-optimality so really what the
collective needs in order to achieve
success is it needs the platform to
learn so the collective will carefully
craft its data but it really needs the
platform to pick up on the patterns that
are in these data points so if the
platform doesn't learn then obviously
the success of the collective will go
down
and so if you want to visualize what
this bound looks like so here we're
plotting uh the success against the size
of the collective on the left hand side
we show this curve for different values
of sides of uh signal uniqueness and on
the right hand side we see
um
this plot while varying the
sub-optimality Epsilon of the classified
okay so the previous result was about
the feature label strategy and now we
can show something similar for the um
feature only strategy so we have the
following lower bound on the success
rate and here really the key parameter
is this little p so p is the minimum
probability of seeing uh y star and
intuitively the way you should think
about this p is requiring P to be large
enough which again
ensures that the success will be large
enough means that there is no
overwhelmingly strong signal for a
competing label so we're in trouble if
for certain X's there is very strong
signal for a label that's not equal to Y
star so we need y star to be
sufficiently probable uh everywhere
so as a takeaway you can see that signal
uniqueness plays a really important role
in both of these results in particular
if the signal uh is unique then even
small collectives can achieve
sufficiently High success rate
um and so now I'll show you an analogous
result for erasing a signal so this was
the objective that we previously defined
and here we study the Erasure strategy
so here given data X Y we report X and
then the most likely label given G of x
so in the example that I gave you where
we censor some sensitive features the
way you should think about this is that
this is the most likely label given your
uh sensor data
okay and so we get this lower Bound in
this setting so here we have a new
parameter uh Tau which intuitively
measures how much information is
contained in the part of X that's not
equal to G of x
so specifically if the outcome Y is
independent of x given G of X then this
Tau will just be equal to zero and our
success rate will be high and then the
more information is contained in x uh
with G of X removed then our success
gets lower
okay and so to test out this Theory we
ran some experiments so we looked at a
data set of 30 000 freelancer resumes
that were scraped from a major gig
platform named indeed
and this is a multi-class multi-label uh
classification problem where the goal is
to predict up to 10 skills in the
software I.T sector based on their
resume
and we use a birth-like tax Transformer
model that's fine-tuned for five epics
and the strategy that we use is we
insert a unique formatting symbol namely
a very unique type of Dash every 20
words so we saw that the theory said if
the signal is very unique then our
success should be high
and for evaluation we've measured the
frequency of the target label y star on
the test set where we insert this Dash
so this is basically directly analogous
to the definition of success that I
showed previously
and we consider both top one and top 10
accuracy so I'll show plots for both top
one and uh
okay so this is what we observe for the
feature label strategy we can see that
actually surprisingly few resumes are
needed for the success to basically
shoot up to one
so success occurs at around 0.1 percent
of the data so that's about 30 resonance
so this is extremely effective and from
left to right you're just seeing uh the
results for different for a different
target class uh y star and
um the bottom row is for top 10 accuracy
the bottom the top row is stopped on
accuracy the bottom one is uh top one
for the feature only strategy we
observe a significantly slower success
is expected because we're only allowed
to manipulate the features so here
um depending on the exact settings
success occurs at around one to ten uh
percent of the data so we need
significantly more data points uh
significantly larger Collective to
actually succeed
so now we wanted to test out
um a couple of other predictions of the
theory so um
we saw that these were the lower bounds
and we saw that uh classifier
sub-optimality played a significant role
namely uh the last hour classifier
learns uh the lower our successes so we
need the classifier to learn as much as
possible okay
and the test is we vary the number of
efforts for which we uh train the model
and indeed we observe that as we
increase the number of efforts the
success goes up
which makes sense because the classifier
picks up more and more on the patterns
and the data that we support
okay so
um also in the feature only setting we
test this hypothesis of
um how much P matters so we said that we
need P to be large enough we need y star
to be a sufficiently probable label for
all data points
and so to test this we randomized some
fraction of the labels in our data to
make y star sufficiently possible so
there can't be any label that
is the right label with overwhelming
probability
um and so again we can see that as we
increase the number of the fraction of
randomized labels success goes up
okay so um those are all the results
that I wanted to show for optimal
prediction so now I just want to briefly
overview what we look at in the context
of convex risk minimization
so here we're assuming that the firm
chooses a model from a parameterized set
um and it chooses this model according
to risk minimization so uh it solves
risk minimization over P where again
recall p is this mixture distribution
composing of the base distribution and
the collective
and we're assuming that this loss
function L is convex
okay so here a natural success measure
is just the distance to some Target
Model Theta star so if you think about
the learner as solving something like
linear regression or logistic regression
then entries of theta basically
correspond to some kind of measure of
feature importance so you can think of
this Theta Star as encoding which
features we want to be more important in
our predictions
okay and so informally we showed that
there exists a strategy that exactly
achieves this
um data star
for a collective size that's upper
bounded by something proportional to the
norm of the gradient of theta star on
the base distribution so just to think
about why this should make sense so if
data star has very large gradient of P0
that means that that Theta star is very
sub-optimal on the distribution that we
started from and if it is very
suboptimal at the beginning then
naturally we need a large Collective to
actually Force the learner to go to
Theta star
on the other hand if Theta star has a
small gradient at the beginning on the
initial distribution that means that
even a priori Theta star wasn't too
sub-optimal which means that we need a
smaller Alpha to force the learner to go
to that Theta star
I'm just trying to
we want something about this
yeah so so there you need to be able to
yeah I think maybe it will be easier to
explain offline so it depends on how uh
large
of a gradient you can induce by picking
the distribution strategically so you
need to be able to uh pick your
distribution P star that will make this
gradient go in a certain direction and
be of a large enough magnitude so this
is divided by how large you can make
that magnitude
so yeah the result is scalariant
um yeah
it is constructive I think just for
Simplicity you didn't want to put it up
on the slot um
is it a feature and label strategy or
like
yeah it's just a strategy over Z so we
don't think about yeah what Z consists
of it consists of features and labels
but in general just some institutions to
see that it's chosen in a way so that
these gradients go in a certain
direction
and sometimes you can achieve that by
just choosing X if you think about a
setting like linear regression basically
it's just saying you can pick X to go in
any direction but it really depends on
itself
Okay so
so
um I told you about a periodical model
that we proposed
um that aims to capture a collective
interacting with the firm's learning
algorithm
uh we characterize the collective
success rate in achieving its goals as a
function of the collective size Alpha
we observed both theoretically
empirically that small collectives can
indeed be very powerful
and I think that there are many
questions to explore in the future in
this framework I think we're only really
scratching the surface for example all
the results that I told you about assume
that there is already a collective in
place
um but it would really be interesting to
understand how collectives form in the
first place because uh joining a
collective may not necessarily be
individually rational uh since all of a
sudden you have to optimize for a larger
group rather than adjust your own self
so it will be interesting to understand
the Dynamics of uh how collectors form
in the first place
um I also haven't really touched upon
this question of what happens if the
population is heterogeneous so we assume
that there is an IID sample from the
population that joins the collective but
in reality there are some individuals
that have a higher leverage some
individuals have lower leverage so can
the collective somehow exploit these
higher leverage individuals uh to
achieve success for maybe a smaller
Alpha
so um with that I want to thank you I'm
happy to take any questions
the algorithm trying to be robust
resistance to this kind of small groups
like 0.1 percent or some tiny groups
trying to change the levels yeah so we
haven't thought about it actually the
way we kind of started working on this
is we felt that there was a lot of
emphasis on this other side on
robustifying algorithms and perhaps not
as much focus on uh on what people can
do to improve their own welfare and
utility and social
um on online platforms uh so yeah the
short answer is no I think this is maybe
like an initial uh step and then you'll
be very interesting to understand what
if both sides are aware of the Strategic
incentives and both sides are trying to
take those into account and like plants
with the other sides
um algorithms yeah I think that would be
interesting
I was just wondering when you had the
um experiments with the optimal
algorithm there were differences I'm
sorry if I missed it there were
differences among how many examples it
took for you to reach the target
prediction is this because like one of
those outputs was more preferable than
another and it was harder for the model
it was one of them you said it was
resume screening so it was one of them
like this is definitely a good resume we
should be forwarded onwards Etc was
there do you know any do you have any
ideas to the reason behind they were why
there was more uh
example necessary for one another you're
talking about
um more examples we needed from left to
right or between this slide right left
or right yeah uh yeah I'm not exactly
sure uh I guess that
um
yeah I'm not sure that I have the right
in the series mix my guess would be that
uh
some predictions are just closer to
being optimal and so it takes less uh
manipulation to make those predictions
actually optimal but their difference
like is the is target class zero like
this is a bad resume and one this has
been okay with the main two this is a
good resume or oh no these different
classes just correspond to different
skills so we want different skills to be
included in the prediction uh given a
resume okay yeah so so yeah there's no
like hierarchy between uh
great I think that